Okay, so Roy Moore, the serial accused child
sex assault or who narrowly lost the Alabama
Senate election in 2017 to Doug Jones after
numerous sexual assault allegations against
him is running again in 2020 and quite frankly,
why wouldn't he?
I mean he almost won, right?
I've told you that despite being almost identical
on many issues, Republicans and Democrats
handle sexual assault allegations against
candidates in their party very, very differently.
Roy Moore got 48.3% of the vote in the election
that he ultimately lost in Alabama.
He almost won, so why wouldn't he run again?
You'll remember compare and contrast that
Al Franken Democratic senator for something
much more minor was forced to resign by both
Republicans, but ultimately because even Democrats
said, yeah, Al Franken should probably go
wild row.
Roy Moore was almost given a Senate seat despite
multiple allegations against him, including
some involving teenage girls.
And the funniest thing about this, if there's
anything funny, and this is basically just
serious, but there's one funny element about
this.
There are prominent Republicans pretending
that Roy Moore is an outlier in a sense that
he's not representative of the Republican
Party, but they're actually wrong, unfortunately
for the Republican Party and for America,
this is exactly representative of the Republican
Party.
Nikki Haley is Donald Trump's former ambassador
to the United Nations.
She's the former governor of South Carolina,
and she came forward to say on Twitter quote,
who in the world or his advisors, at what
point does he think another run?
We'll have a different response.
He does not represent our Republican Party.
The hell is she talking about?
This guy is completely representative of the
Republican Party and you know that because
almost every Republican in Alabama voted for
him despite multiple sexual assault allegations
that guests get against him and he barely
lost.
He got 48.3% of the vote.
If Republicans had a problem with Roy Moore,
if they felt that a candidate riddled with
sexual assault allegations against them, including
those involving teenage girls, they wouldn't
have almost elected him.
US senator from Alabama.
Trump was elected despite allegations that
he sexually assaulted countless women, including
an underage girl, Alabama Republicans nominated
Roy Moore.
They selected him from a choice of Republican
options and then almost all of them voted
for him to a degree that almost got him the
Senate seat.
48.3% of the total votes.
So let's be clear, yes, there are lots of
Republicans like Nikki Haley who see Roy Moore's
a second candidate, another candidacy.
I don't know what number it makes as a strategic
mistake.
They say, well, if someone else ran against
Democrat Doug Jones in the very red state
of Alabama, we would likely win this seat
back from, from Democrats.
But with Roy Moore, Doug Jones might get himself
reelected.
That's true, but that's simply the Republican
party seeing this as sport, which they do,
and seeing this as wins and losses.
We'll see what happens in the Republican primary
in Alabama.
There's still lots of time for other Republicans
to get in and challenge Roy Moore.
Very long list of possible candidates already
surfacing either way, regardless of this seat.
I don't see the math for Democrats to take
control of the Senate in 2020, just because
of which seats are up for reelection.
But Doug Jones holding onto this seat would
be terrific because it's one seat.
We don't have to win back in 2022 in order
to take control of the Senate.
Then again, I don't see any path for Democrats
to take control in 2020, but still holding
the Doug Jones seat rather than losing it
back to a Republican, which is arguably predictable
in Alabama is one seat we don't have to make
up for in 2022 potentially to take control
back of the sentence.
So let's do what we can.
When the time comes to help Doug Jones get
reelected in Alabama,